what's going on guys this is rob and
word has reached my ears that apparently
in that poster that has like all the
glass and all that kind of stuff
that cathode shows up there and
initially i didn't realize it was him
right like somebody sent me up sent me
an image and they were like this looks
like cathode right and then once i
looked it up i realized it's everywhere
people have been talking about it for
like the last week i don't know how i
missed it but uh but yeah it took me a
minute to see it but when i did i was
like damn that kind of does look like a
phone it also looks like the creature
from the black lagoon but it looks like
a thumb and so it was like damn all
right so it was one thing when we were
like speculating right because catholic
and the scarlet witch go hand in hand
here's a big misconception i do want to
correct though so people always talk
about like the house of m scarlet witch
and how powerful she was and all that
kind of stuff cathode gave wanda really
the the nature of her powers right the
the peak of her abilities not really the
peak but the ability to like alter
reality and things like that what made
wanda so powerful during the events of
house of m was actually something called
the life force which basically amplified
the powers that she got from catholic
several times over it's how she was able
to wipe basically 98 of the mutant
population or at least take away powers
of 98 of the mutant population across
the multiverse because originally it was
just a singular universe but then later
on beast of the x-men basically realizes
it was across the whole multiverse as
far as i'm aware marvel used that to
book in an explanation as to why it is
during the events of old man logan that
mutants just never came back that
basically after the x-men and various
mutants were were essentially killed off
and like the villains conquering the
world that mutants just didn't really
emerge anymore that the scarlet witch is
the reason why but regardless uh that's
something that i felt like clearing up
but here's the thing even then right all
right look the big question people are
going to have right they're going to say
okay we got to throw it on once cathode
on one side weighing in at however much
this guy weighs because he's enormous
versus cathone weighing in at whatever
he weighs right who wins oh kazon hands
down here's the thing man
here's the thing about these guys a
really good example of this there's an
old dr strange story from back in the
day where dormammu actually invokes the
power of catholic and refers to him as
like the great catholic right like this
great magical being the amount of power
that cathode has and that's something
that we talked about before here on geek
culture explain right the amount of
power this guy has
is absolutely nuts now the big question
you have to ask here is that if cathone
is basically the guy in doctor strange
too who's maybe the one manipulating
wanda or whatever the case is and then
there's also somebody like doramu then
how do these two tie together and i
still say it's the concept of the hell
lords kind of being reworked by the
marvel cinematic universe now
technically dormammu is considered a
lord of chaos he's like schumachorath or
any of those guys out there right he's
not really a hell lord or anything like
that technically duramamu is a fall team
is really what he is right he comes from
like the faulting dimension basically a
dimension of magical energy and so on
and so forth he conquered the dark
dimension with his sister umar they
created the mindless ones and so on and
so forth he's basically been an enemy of
doctor strange ever since cathode was a
was a demon or really was more like an
elder god who existed on earth and the
reality here is that when it comes to
beings and the kind of power they
possess the dimensions they hail from
don't really matter they don't really
have much of a bearing for example like
odin is from asgard odin's really really
powerful odin would get curb stomped by
franklin richards and he's just the son
of reed richards of the fantastic four
but he's a universal constant and he can
alter reality on a universal level the
molecule man owen reese can alter
reality on a multiversal level and he
was just a guy right i mean he was just
he was literally a dude who's performing
an experiment accidentally made a cosmic
cube and absorb half of it into himself
right so the guy could basically do
anything so just because a person hails
from like earth or an earthly dimension
does not mean that they are not powerful
technically cathode is an elder god that
originated on earth ultimately he was
defeated by a tomb and then took up
refuge in his own dimension but not
before creating the dark hole and then
leaving it on earth as a way for him to
return and that in and of itself when it
comes to the mcu that's really what it
is about right i mean i love fear theory
crafting i love coming up with like
these crazy and wild and insane ideas
but you guys have for the most part been
right to a degree right the the reality
is the mcu always just goes with the
simplest thing and the simplest thing
here is that cathone is a demon entity
that exists out there that created the
dark hole and the dark hole in turn
allows a person who uses it to basically
become a vessel for cathode right the
more they use it the more cathode can
tap into them this is doubly so because
the history between wanda and catholic
they go hand in hand right cathone is as
much a
you know energy-based father to scarlet
witch as magneto is her biological
father kind of but not really depending
on what era of comics you're talking
about the the important thing here is
that it makes the most sense that
catholic would be there but again
referencing this relationship that could
potentially exist between catholic and
dormammu how does this work well let's
be honest with ourselves if the
motivation of dormammu in the marvel
cinematic universe is to expand the dark
dimension and to conquer territories
he can't be the only one
[Music]
he can't be the only one out there just
wanting to conquer other realities and
take them over right it would just seem
kind of weird he'd be the only one to do
that so somebody like catholic could
very well exist out there now what the
origin of catholic is
here's the thing i have a hard time
believing that when like like patrick
stewart's charles xavier was was saying
like let's tell dr strange the truth and
baron mordo starts talking to him he's
like once upon a time there were elder
gods who existed on earth that predate
man by billions of years and then they
were just kind of cool and they were
exploring magic but then eventually they
all just lost their right they just went
off the rails and started attacking each
other and cathode was the most powerful
so in order to bring all the chaos to an
end
basically gaia the spirit of the earth
banged the earth's atmosphere and they
ended up creating like demiurge and then
demiurge in turn killed all of the elder
gods absorbed them the ones that didn't
didn't get killed they took off to other
dimensions and then he merged with the
sun like i have a hard time believing
because that's the origin that's the
origin of the comics i have a hard time
believing they're going to do that in
doctor strange too it would just seem
weird you know like it was just like
people would just be like what like this
really is a multiverse it's a movie of
madness right doctor strange too movie
of madness right
right the plot of madness that's what it
would come across people would just be
like this is ridiculous like even for
the marvel cinematic universe so i don't
know exactly what his origin is going to
be but i will say this that in terms of
the marvel cinematic universe in terms
of catholic his relationship with
dormammu one it makes the most sense
that if catholic does exist in the mcu
which seemingly he does and that if
catholic is the source of scarlet
witch's power or at the very least by
creating the dark hole and then the
scarlet witch taking it and reading it
she's basically allowed herself to
become susceptible to being corrupted by
catholic and that scholar witch is
chasing after america chavez basically
being controlled by cathode as this kind
of earthly avatar or maybe it's one of
those things where she's being forced to
do it right like she heard her kids
crying or screaming at the end of wanda
vision she takes off what the hell is it
and then catherine's standing there and
like he's creating an illusion of her
kids but she doesn't know it's an
illusion and he's like if you want your
children back go get america chavez for
me bring her to me and then you can have
your kids and you can live happily ever
after or something along those lines who
knows who cares but whatever it is she's
chasing after america chavez catholic
wants america chavez so that catholic
can escape his own dimension and then
start wreaking havoc across the entirety
of the universe or even just the
multiverse whatever the case happens to
be that when you're you're talking about
a guy like that you are really talking
about a being who's just that powerful
the funny thing about catholic is he
can't leave his own dimension he can't
escape his own dimension it's the caveat
to his character cathone has always been
a person who's been trapped inside his
own dimension and needs an earthly host
in order to escape it's the big
difference between like catholic and
dormammu durmamu like routinely shows up
and just starts
right with like doctor strange just just
starts causing problems right like he
does that
all the time
in marvel comics right it's just one of
those things but when catholic shows up
that's when you know things are really
starting to pop off and again if
catholic is trapped in his own dimension
if he is forcing wanda to get america
chavez so he can escape then it would
also make sense that either he's trapped
in his own realm he's looking to expand
his own realm because you would have to
imagine if someone like america chavez
has the ability to jump from one reality
to the next she's got to have some
multiversal equivalent of like cosmic
awareness those guys who don't know what
that is cosmic awareness is a concept
that is largely confined to either
cosmic entities or beings that are super
powerful operating on a cosmic scale
adam warlock quasar people like that
people who basically know what's going
on in the universe at essentially any
point in time it doesn't mean they can
stop whatever's happening it just simply
means they know that it's happening
right so it's it's like raising
awareness right now there's a problem
there you know now it's somebody else's
job to fix it
but that's kind of how this that's
that's how that cosmic awareness works
with america chavez you'd almost have to
imagine it's the same thing she'd have
to know where she was going she's like
nightcrawler from the x-men teleporting
around she can just jump from one
universe to the next otherwise who knows
what kind of universe you could she
could end up in now that may be part of
the mystery that her powers don't work
that way she doesn't know what universe
she's going to but say for example she
does then someone like catholi seizing
that power of america chavez it'd be
very very easy for him to in turn just
hop and skip across the multiverse and
conquer universes much faster than
dormammu could the other part of this is
that if we wanted to bring dormammu into
this it could be this kind of marvel
cinematic universe equivalent of like
the space race right everyone's after
america chavez everyone's trying to get
the power of america chavez and what
america chavez is doing is just fleeing
for her life right wanda is the physical
avatar the earthly avatar being used by
ketho to try to get america childish
dormammu is trying to do the same thing
and any other beings who were out there
trying to escape their own realm could
possibly be doing the same thing one of
the things to know here is that if we
leave out the whole idea of loki and we
say like the multiverse existed except
that loki just kind of set it free then
that could mean that america chavez has
basically been doing this her whole life
right she's like sylvie from loki right
just kind of always on the run always
hopping around from one place to the
next this is all america chavez's life
has been for a number of years and she's
constantly been chased by like dormammu
and she's constantly been chased by
shumogorath and other people like that
right maybe that's why shumagorath
appears on earth in the first place it's
because shumogorath is hunting for
america chavez and we know america
chavez was at some point in the sanctum
sanctorum of doctor strange we know that
from the trailer so it's like schumer
gorath and it's like cathode and it's
like dormammu these guys are all just
gunning for this girl and it just
happens to be the scarlet witch is one
of the people who were being used who
knows maybe scarlet witch has her own
agenda right she wants her kids so she's
hunting for america travis whatever the
case is in terms of circling back around
i guess to the main point of this video
because we've kind of digressed here a
little bit as far as cathode goes in the
grand tapestry of people who are
powerful at least borrowing from mobile
comics and assuming that that kind of
translates to the mcu catholics almost
near the top this guy's ridiculously op
on a universal level right on the
universal he's he's he's nowhere near
like the living tribunal right or like
the molecule man or the one above all or
like the beyonders or anybody like that
he's nowhere near that level of power
like the chaos king would obliterate
catholic and not even by a little bit i
mean he was just
right that would be the i mean literally
the chaos king amatsu mikabashi this guy
killed basically every god in the
multiverse it was kind of nuts
but that's entirely possible here so
again you know i think that that having
cathode in the movie would be cool i
think it'd be really really really
really awesome because it would really
tie in well with the nature of wanda
especially when we're talking about the
dark hole the biggest issue with the
dark hole though is that routinely in
the runaways tv show and agents of
shield the nature of the dark hole is
that it is fed by basically dark
dimension energy and the ruler of the
dark dimension is dormammu so how it is
you reconcile those two things i'm not
entirely sure the mcu could just change
it right they could just be like
actually that was never the case it was
just powered by cathode and it's always
been that way the people in agents of
shield and runaways they were just
idiots they had no idea what they were
dealing with they were misinformed right
it comes by way of like doctor strange
or mamamoo whoever it doesn't really
matter but again that's kind of the cool
thing here is that there's a lot of
possibilities here with cathone being
invoked presumably and dr strange too
if this one little image that we've seen
is to be believed
this little shard of glass that we saw
in the poster that looks like a throne
if we are going to take this its gospel
truth and run with it uh then yeah
things would be really really
fascinating with him in there because i
gotta be honest man if they have if if
the power of catholic in the marvel
cinematic universe is anywhere
comparable to his power in the comics
no way anybody stands a chance not a
chance and i wouldn't be surprised if
for all the power that wanda has she's
only got a sampling of the power that
cathode has because that's how it works
in the comics
she gets this small little fraction of
cathode's power but if that dude managed
to escape his dimension and show up in
the main marvel universe in his actual
real physical form with 100 of his power
everybody would fall the cosmic entities
dr strange galactus anybody out there
would fall with the exception of the
absolute most powerful reality
manipulators on a multiversal scale no
one would be able to defeat this guy so
hopefully we see something comparable to
that in doctor strange too but that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
to an end thank you all for watching and
i will catch you all later
peace